Hello, everyone at Jamiseon.  We will begin part of the
Chesley Morning Brief for Tuesday, July 7, bringing you happy investment plans
.   Let’s
find out how the Chinese market closed yesterday with Director Wang. Yes,
yesterday, while telling investors to trade tech stocks, the
breaking news was that the Shang Index stood at 0.65%
.  The Heisei Tag Index
rose by 94% to plus 0.94 points, and came down
to the outer sea of ​​the 3rd floor of the giant area during the regular time
.  Looking at the sectors, yesterday
sectors such as energy, consumer goods, and finance
showed strength, while communication, IT,
and materials sectors accelerated.   Oh, Jeong Ui-hwa told
Energy Kwon Yong-ju to come yesterday with margin calculations and expectations for dividends in the cup
.  Oh, Batterer
went up 1.4%, Shin Ho-pen went up 2.6%, and China Shinwha
went up 3%.
Shippers also made money thanks to strong second-quarter earnings and the inflow of funds for low-price buying
.  Culture Hahan-eul rose 2.7%, Jang
Yong-seon rose 4%, and Hwatbang Gwahan
rose 6%.  Consumer-related stocks
rebounded again yesterday.  Bijomadae rose 1%, and the
main stock went up 2.3%.  Oh,
Hescare-related stocks
showed strength for 0 days due to the inflow of funds for low-price buying.  The flat limit
increased by 3% for 4th place, and the flower-movement limit
increased by 3% for 1st place.  Stocks related to the momentum have also risen, driven by expectations of this quarter's
performance and increased revenue from additional overseas orders
.  4won Tech
gives you 4%.
Stocks that we understand well.  Yesterday, we decided to reverse the 6% and go for a new win
.  My colleague Yushi
got a plus 5%.  This time,
some state-run businesses were also unaware of the expectations for the expansion of the semi-city
.  Gigi rose by 1.2%,
Haekwang Information by 4%, SMS by
2.6%, and Jeonjeon Tech by 4.5%
.  Hong Kong-related stocks were a bit
volatile yesterday.  Looking at Hong Kong Heungseon Tech,
Tencent was up 4.8% yesterday
.  There was one person yesterday morning as well;
Alibaba went up 2% and TestMe went
up 1.4%.   On
the other hand, the PCB CC and related
subject taxes have all been adjusted.
Seungin Tech dropped by 4%, Younger Sibling Precision by
3.6%, and
Jeongryo by 3%.  Oh, regarding the specific interest
rate for beliefs, I said to set the inflammation by 5bp yesterday
.  The specific interest rate
plus inflammation 4b teacher and the
foreign currency exchange rate went well, around inflammation 2-3%
. Hmm,
thank you.  Uh, while you were talking,
I was looking at the table we show you every day at the very top, and I
thought I should ask you something. Uh, if you look at the top right, the
CSI 300 by industry,
yes.   You
show us the data for one day, five days, three months, and so on, continuing from the beginning of the year.
If you look at it, well, since IT has
risen about 46% since the beginning of the year, it is overwhelming.   yes
.  And if you scroll down,
Communication is at 48%.
Hey,
what well-known stocks are included in Communication?
Oh,
all the optical communication-related stocks have
been included.
Why is it communication?
Well, industry [laughs] anyway, is
that so? Yes, since it can probably be
described as telecommunications,
then you could understand it as IT in a broad sense
.
yes.  And looking at the sectors that have fallen significantly,
real estate is naturally in a bad state and interest
rates are high.
no.  In China, real estate...
ah, in China, interest rates are on a downward trend, right? Hmm, that's
correct.  It is just maintaining that
trend.  Or, the current specific new product
continues to maintain around 1.74%
.
So the height isn't that high.   hmm.
So now, overall,
there is anxiety regarding the upper.   hmm.
Uh, when it comes to real estate, well, you have to
look at various factors, but
uh, if it's real estate prices, or uh, what do you call that construction thing
?  Yes,
among things like the scale of development, what exactly are you
worried about?  Oh, this
is the second development of the second-minute price.  Development companies have
very high debts, you know.   It involves things
like sales revenue, but if it
doesn't come out, there is some internal debt and even a
disc problem, but most of these reasons
have been alleviated.  It has been resolved.
Because the structure is almost completely finished,
but right now the real estate upper is only being expanded in first-tier cities
.  The 2-line, 3-phase, 4-
city system still doesn't have time.  So, it will probably take
some time, but I have
no reservations.  In terms of actual performance, it is
maintaining a level of near-deficit, surplus, deficit, and surplus.   It
seems like construction companies would benefit if the volume of construction or the scale of orders increased, but
no turning point is visible in that regard yet.
Um. Yes, yes, that's right.  Probably early,
early.  Hmm,
I understand.
I asked because it’s been a while since I’ve been interested in keeping an eye on how things are going in this industry.  The featured
stock below is Hwabong Chemical.  yes.  The pictorial
has released results.  The stock price went up by nearly 5% yesterday
. This company was a Chinese
spandex
manufacturing company.  MS maintains a share of around 20% to
25%, and ranks
second globally based simply on MS.  The Chinese
market is number one.  Uh, CR5 is
70%.  The number one company
is Hyosung TNT.  that's right.
Hyo-
eo's ranking for the third quarter
is expected to increase by 112% starting from Dong-ui.  Historically, it is
expected to increase by more than 111% compared to the same period in the second quarter.
Education is also increasing by more than 50%, and
compared to the consensus, it was mutual.
Spatex, a member of the mutual association, achieved a loss-making victory
due to price increases and factory vulcanization rises
.  If we're talking about market
data, this time Seungchan is
coming out at almost 320,000.  Compared to the same period,
historical accuracy increased by 5%, while demand
increased by 4% to 17.4% compared to the same period.  So this price kept going up
.
The price of the second unit
has been increased by about 7 won per unit.  The No. 2 Spride per unit
increased by 28% year-on-year to 13,000 in appearance, and education increased by about 27%
.  The price has dropped a bit recently
.  So
there is also a possibility of additional calculations for Sprider in the third quarter.  As of July
2, Sprider
has already fallen by about 12% compared to the second quarter, with an external size of 15,000.  Historically, the employment
spride was around 60,000 won
.  So it is a much lower
level than this.  Even after going up now, it is still low
.  The average is roughly 1.7 to
2.5, so even if this
spread price rises, it is not a big burden
.  Therefore,
looking at the Chunggu Securities Report, we maintained a buy recommendation due to factors such as global spandex price increases
and improved spreads
.  Compared to the original, next year
's rankings
were pushed forward at 4 billion, 5 billion, and 6 billion respectively, and compared to the supreme, they were
used as large cannons at 32%, 30%, 29.5%, and 5%.  Uh, well, I wo
n't present a target TP.  You can
receive roughly 20 times from this company.  Uh,
then if we apply the 20th PR this year, the
TP could come out to 12.  I
wiped out nearly 45% compared to yesterday's closing price.
Thank you. I would like to
ask about just a few parts of what you wrote that I didn't quite understand.  First of all, it is
China's largest spandex manufacturer, and regarding the
market share, it is 20 to
25%, and within China, it is 20 to
25%
. Yes, that is correct.  Globally it's 10%,
10%,
and here CR
5.
Just
combining the 1st place up to the 5th place, the market
growth rate is 70%.  Ah, you told me that the top five
companies account for about 70% of the entire market
.
Uh, there are occasional talks about price increases and things like that,
yes.
Uh, we usually call this PQC analysis.
How does PQC relate to the causal factors of improved performance?
All of them apply.
All of it,
because this
spandex is the
number one company, the former company.  The third-place
company reconciles.
Hwahae was derived from that company.
Um,
so there is
no reconnaissance over there. This company is continuously conducting reconnaissance
. This company and
that company where Hyosun TNC is located are conducting reconnaissance.   So
now, Q is continuously rising, and on this
day of reconciliation,
the overall supply in the market was reduced.  So, the blood pressure is
rising.  Since C is a vertical resolution of this hole,
Sig is also improving
.  So, it becomes a PQ solution.   Can we
view the current "kick-in" market as being about how cheaply a company supplies products, just like in the early semiconductor market where there were more than 10 players? Yes, that is
correct.  You can look at it that way.
Because
after COVID-19, most of the Spandex companies
went into deficit, with the exception of the luxury business.
So there were a lot of bankruptcy issues.   Over
the past few years, the
assumption is that the supply issues have been fully resolved and now it is simply time to come back.  Judging by what you're
saying, the top five
companies hold a 70% market share,
yes.  Uh, just like in the mobile phone industry where
only Apple makes money, Samsung Electronics makes
a little, and the companies from third place onwards all lose money,
uh, it seems that not all five companies are
enjoying profits either
.   The
third-ranked company was rescued.  And
seeing what you're saying...   yes
.  Roughly speaking, it seems like it is a
structure where only the top two companies can make money
.  If you go down to the US, this
cost structure isn't very good.  We
have to raise funds, and since
there is no agreement when making decisions, it’s a very ambiguous situation.
So, things like first and second place rotations... because there are so
many fans.  Since there are many identical items and
costs are well managed, you can keep
coming in.  So, we can
probably decide on a company like this. Hmm, I
understand.
I get the feeling this is a stock you can just watch and trade. Is that
right?
Ah,
or maybe it's self-investment. Uh, this is the
same question again, because this
company has been somewhat overlooked since it's not a semiconductor company.
Yes, but since earnings are strong, I think that
companies that continue to adjust their stock prices based on upward and downward trends can expect their stock
prices to rise even after future earnings reports
.  I think I will need some time
.  yes.  Ah, it seems you introduced the idea that this is a company with consistently
upward earnings and a good industry outlook, but
because of IT Sol, the multiple is
positioned a bit lower than it should originally be
.
Yes, that is correct.
All right.  Yesterday I mentioned the 10 Center, and
today you
mentioned Hwabong Chemical, which has a similar condensation.   I will
add it to my watchlist.   Let
's look at the US market from yesterday.  I
thought the index just went up because the IT sector did,
but looking at Micron's stock price, it seems to be only slightly higher. Let's
find out exactly what happened with Pro Chang-min Jang, who is preparing for this.
please.  I will report on the US market conditions from yesterday
.  I would say that yesterday was a day when
AI trading revived in the US market
.
If we look at the major indices first, the SP 500
rose 0.86%.  The Nasdaq
rose the most, with gains in the 1% range and the Dow rising 0.2% and 2%.  The general index
showed the largest increase, rising to the 2% range.  This was
clearly a technical move regarding the rise in the index.
The market, which had been shaken recently by profit-taking in the semiconductor sector, rebounded today as
funds returned to the semiconductor and AI infrastructure sectors
.
However, I would like to point out first that this was closer to a rebound driven by relief as the pressure was released, rather than a rise caused by new positive fundamental news
If you look at the right sector, you can see that the Jangseong area is
clearly visible today.
While the government, technology, consumer discretionary, and communications sectors, which account for a large portion of the SP 500, rose and pulled the index up
, defensive sectors such as consumer staples,
utilities, and real estate
showed a decline.  You can view the risk of money flowing out of safe areas and into
tech stocks as the
market.
Next, we will briefly go over interest rates and oil prices
.  The 10-year government bond
yield remained largely unchanged at 4.47% and 47%
.  Oil prices fell slightly
to $0.50 based on WTI,
continuing their downward trend below $10.
If you look at P-Tech and major stocks on the left,
Apple rose 1.5%, Tesla
rose 6.2%, and Roadcom rose 4.4%
.  Overall, it
showed an upward trend, while Microsoft
showed a slight increase of 0.9% to 9%.
And if you look at the semiconductor sector, My
Micro
showed a moderate rise of 2.5%.  With AMD
rising 7.8% and 8% and TSMC
rising 4.9%, the semiconductor sector also
showed an overall upward trend.
Next, I will mention some individual stocks worth noting
.  First, Tesla
rose by over 6%.  Last week, the second-quarter
delivery volume was announced, exceeding 480,000 units
and falling short of market expectations by more than 70,000 units
.  On the day of the announcement, the
stock price actually fell due to valuation concerns, but
today it rebounded as news emerged that it would expand to include robotaxi services and
analysts raised their target prices based on delivery volume and progress in autonomous driving
.
While electric vehicles are important for Tesla, the stock is also being traded based on autonomous
driving and robot AI narratives, so you can
view today's rise as a revival of those narratives.  And
another stock you should look at here is that
Lucid, an electric vehicle company,
has risen by more than 10%.  The reason for the rebound
today after previously showing a downward trend
appears to be the renewed prominence of the autonomous robotaxi narrative.  Lucid is the exclusive partner supplying
Gravity SUVs to the robotaxi program being promoted by Wuhan and Nuro
.   This is a
company that is already producing verification vehicles ahead of deployment in 2027.
Next, I will talk about AMD.   The stock
surged nearly 8% today, and the
direct trigger for today's rise was Goldman
Sachs significantly raising its target price from $450
to $640.   There is some
expectation that AMD will announce a new lag system to compete against Mvidia and new hyperscaler customers ahead of its own AI event called Advancing AI this month
.   hmm.
And there was more noteworthy news today, which
connects to the autonomous driving story I just mentioned.  Japanese fully
autonomous driving startup Tuning has brought in
AMD Ventures, AMD's venture arm, as a
new investor while raising funds, and
at the same time, has started shifting
about 10% of its AI training volume, which had previously relied almost exclusively on NVIDIA, to
AMD.
Uh, the reason this part is significant is that while
Tesla and Lucid
were benefiting from the applied aspects of autonomous driving, AMD
appears to have dug into the underlying computing chips that those autonomous driving companies use to train their AI.  While NVIDIA has previously dominated the automotive AI learning
market, this can be
seen as a signal that AMD is starting to be adopted as an alternative
.
And the next company I would like to mention
is Aristan Nets, which
rose by over 8% in today's trading session. This
company manufactures
high-speed network switches that connect GPUs within AI data centers
.  When you say yes, people
usually tend to think mainly of chips like NVIDIA,
but I mentioned this company as an example to show that the
network equipment connecting those chips can also
benefit
.
Finally, Broadcom rose by over 4%
.  I believe this was the most noteworthy
issue today.  Roadcom and
Apple announced today via an SEC filing that they have extended their custom chip supply partnership
until 2031
.
Broadcom has long supplied
RF, Wi-Fi, and Bluetooth connectors for the iPhone and
is a key partner of Apple.   We have
definitely secured a new contract to develop and supply custom ASIC silicon for multiple generations of Apple products
.  This is important because
Apple has consistently shown a tendency to in-house semiconductors, such as with the M Series 10 or its own
modems
.  Therefore, there was underlying concern in the market that
Apple might eventually replace the Broadcup volume
with its own chips, but it
appears that this contract extension has significantly alleviated those underlying concerns.
So, the message running through the rise of the companies I mentioned earlier is that
today the market has broadly bought back
various layers of the AI ​​value chain—that is,
chips such as GPUs, CPUs, and custom ASICs, as well as
network equipment connecting them and
AI applications like autonomous robots
.
Next, I will also point out a macro indicator
.  The UR ISM
services index was released yesterday.  This is an
indicator created based on surveys of U.S. service industry purchasing managers. Since the service sector
accounts for the majority of the U.S. economy, you can
view it as playing a role similar to a filling mechanism for the U.S. economy.   If it
exceeds 50, it can be interpreted as economic expansion; if it falls below, it can be interpreted
as contraction.  The
June figures released yesterday showed a
slight slowdown compared to April on a headline basis, but were
still in the expansionary range.  It
also met market expectations.  It has been
showing signs of expansion for 24 consecutive months
.  For reference, the
manufacturing PMI released this January was
53.3. If it falls by 0.7% to
7% points compared to May, this can also be
considered as being in the expansion zone for six consecutive months.
So, you can view it as a picture where both the manufacturing and service sectors are
slowing down gradually but continuing to maintain expansion
.  The Vice President told me that he would provide further details in Part 2
.  [Laughs]
Uh, to summarize, today
funds returned to the entire AI value chain, and it was a market that
rebounded a bit.
And I would say that it was a market that rose broadly across chip networks and AI applications, such as Tesla, AMD, Arista, and
Broadcom
.  That's all.
thank you  Since you meticulously explain
what kind of work each company does and
where its revenue comes from when you introduce them, I
think it makes it easier for people like me, who don't know much about American companies, to understand.
Thank you again for the thorough organization today.  As I looked up while you were speaking, I noticed that among the
stocks hitting 52-week highs, there are many major stocks in
sectors such as healthcare and finance, in addition to IT
.  So I thought that while major stocks are still rising, the market is
spreading further, and many other stocks are
rising as well. As I was
coming here looking through the headline news this morning, I
saw news reports that the Bao Index continues to hit new highs, even though it has risen relatively less than the SMT 500 or Nasdaq.  So, I also thought that in the US, the
index isn't showing a correction, but rather
the market is being
maintained and supported as the momentum continues to spread to other sectors
.  thank you
As Pro Changmin suggested in this section, we will take a closer look at the details
with Vice President Choi Ho, and then
move on to virtual assets.   This
is Junhyeokju.  What happened to the virtual assets
?   yes
.  I will tell you about the market.   I
think we can view yesterday as a market where positive and negative factors acted very strongly and clearly.  I have marked two red boxes.
The price itself is
$64,000, but yesterday the fluctuations were
very large.  So, uh, yesterday around
8:50 to 9:00
was the time slot for the first box.
In the first box, it showed a sharp decline as
news emerged that MicroStigi had sold about 3,600 Bitcoins
.  So, in the second box, I showed you how Bitcoin
dropped to around $61,000, uh, the high $61,000 range, and then
rose again
. Regarding this second box, it
seems that the NYS New York Stock Exchange 250th anniversary event took place yesterday.  This took place
in the White House's military office, where they
rang the bell, conducted various interviews, and the
ministers each took
turns speaking.
So, President Trump is
creating a Trump account there.  I
am creating a Trump account, and
Bitcoin could be added to that Trump account
.  It showed
signs of rebounding once again while giving off that kind of nuance
.  So, while the
recent
trend has shown a tendency to react more sensitively to negative news and rebound only when it comes to bad news, barely reacting to positive news, yesterday's performance seemed to
accept the positive news as positive, which I
think can be seen as a positive sign.
After Microstage hinted at the possibility that Bitcoin could now be sold, that
sentiment formed, but that
sentiment was not just sentiment; it actually
led to a sell-off.
The fact that 3,500 units were sold so quickly could have
continued to spread a somewhat negative atmosphere in the market, but you can
view yesterday as Trump and the White House somewhat restoring that
.  So, if
you look at the long-term Bitcoin chart, you can see that it has
settled at the 200-week moving average and appears to be
closing, and it is currently trading above that level
.  So, if you are
placing an order above the 200-week moving average,
since we can confirm that the point below $60,000 was definitely the bottom, you just need to
make sure that this line is held.  Uh, as I just
mentioned, it says "
Trump and the White House," which is completely nonsensical.
I think the timing was a bit perfect yesterday.  So, after Trump's price
dropped, suddenly crypto is
too big a market.  Crypto I
like.
I think I was a bit bewildered because the news came out so suddenly like this.  It’s not like this is about suddenly
investing in crypto or anything like that; it just
seems like it was a day when the price of Bitcoin was somewhat influenced by what Trump said.  On the right is
the news that came out early this morning.  There is a
team within the White House Economic Advisory Committee that performed the best on Bitcoin.  It seems like this is news from that team.
Initially,
Trump
signed an executive order regarding the strategic holding of Bitcoin in 2025, and as
part of that, they are still laying the groundwork for it
.  And as
news
emerged suggesting that they are trying to make things a bit more solid structurally, it rose once again, and
the price of Bitcoin has now
reached nearly $65,000
. You can consider this to be roughly accurate.  Uh, if
you look at the BitPeGrady Index, you
can see that it has risen a little to the fear zone. This number is
recording around 24.
I think we can just provide a strategy update.
That strategy sold a
total of
about 3,500 Bitcoins on the market last week and, uh, the week before last
.
Uh, I
remember mentioning that although the trend was bad last week, the Bitcoin price trend wasn't bad last week.  So, the ability to absorb it in the market has
developed to some extent.
Well, from my perspective, I think that is a somewhat positive
aspect.  So, there were a
lot of people mentioning that the strategy issues had already been priced in, and
personally, I thought that the trends yesterday and last week allowed us to acknowledge those points to some extent
.  So, Strategy
currently holds about 2.3 billion in cash
.  As they announced plans to spend on
dividends and interest-related expenses in the second quarter,
the market may understand this as an attempt to look after shareholders and
research preferred stocks. However, the fact that the strategy, which was
dominated by Bitcoin, has
shifted its stance to selling has
clearly worsened sentiment, and
we were able to confirm yesterday that this was actually executed
.  If
you look at the main section, I have brought the simplest issue
.  Uh, it says here that
Securitide, the stock that looks most like a stock, has listed
.  It is a
company that went public on July 2nd.  Uh, last
Thursday, Securitize went public on the New York Stock Exchange under the
ticker symbol SEZ, and
it was originally a SPAC.   This
is a case of a reverse listing, where the company went public by merging with a SPAC.
Securitize is a company
engaged in the business of tokenizing stocks
.  So, if you do that, the SEC works for
some things but not for others
.  I have mentioned before that it is not recognized for some reason, but to reiterate,
currently, SC is officially recognizing only the form of the shareholder name being listed
.  Uh, Securitize is the one that
follows those guidelines well
.  So, there is an
interesting anecdote about Securitize: on the very
day of its market listing, they
actually issued Securitize tokens so that people could participate in the market
.  You
can understand that
Securitice is a company that clearly engages in the toll or stock market, and that it is the
only company currently successfully implementing the issuer guarantee model
.  So, when considering
which company to look at when looking at Securitize Talk stocks, I would say that
Securitize is at the
forefront
.  It is also the
most advanced in the guidelines.  Since
Securitize is significantly ahead in terms of scale, I
think you should take a closer look at the company.  I didn't mention this to
recommend the company, but rather because it is true that
Securitize is currently the
furthest ahead in the long-term watch race
.  That's all.
It's the name of a company called Securitize.   Is the
company talking about
such and such assets
?  Uh, I am currently prioritizing stocks, but since it is an
asset called tokens, it could be
gold. However, in the case of gold, you have to
directly hold the physical assets, such as through an STO, to be
able to do that.  In the
case of stocks, since you just need to contact the company to
determine if the issuer guarantees it and
add it to the shareholder list, it appears to me that
Securitize is primarily approaching stock
companies—that is, securities—first
.  I confirmed that since there are plenty of opportunities to expand other assets,
Securitize is primarily focusing on securities
.  So, regarding the statement that a stock company's securities
become "tokenized," I am
embarrassed to ask such a basic question, but I
understand it as the concept that small-scale investments are possible.
However, there are other advantages as well
.  Hey, there is a reason why the issuer guarantee model is the
only one recognized by the SEC
.  Only the issuer-guaranteed
model is listed as an actual entry in the shareholder register
.  The issuer correction model allows shareholders to
fully enjoy the values ​​and rights they are entitled to
.
So, if you actually
say you bought Securitize privileged knowledge, you
become a Securitize shareholder.  At
Toss Securities, we actually
do a lot of fractional trading, but this is a slightly different
method. It is actually split, and
there was even a possibility that it was made to look like it was split. However, even though it is actually split, you can still
enjoy all the rights related to dividends and voting rights that actual shareholders are entitled to; you can
view this as the model that Spice is currently operating.   yes
.  I am curious about the specific method by which
the rights held by shareholders are distributed in small amounts, but I will
ask about that later.  thank you
Today, we also looked into a new company called Securitize
.  I would like to
wrap up a little early here.  I would like to
thank the members of Chaebusan who joined us.  We will see you in the second part with a little more
detail.
Thank you to everyone who joined us.  no see.
[Music]
เฮ
Hello.
Join Chesley Investment Point for a happy investment journey. Chesley Morning
Brief. Today is Tuesday, July 7th
.
Is it Tuesday?  Yes. We will now
begin the second part of the episode.
Ah, the sound of
rain coming into my ears from outside in the morning feels so refreshing, and it is
really nice that the rain is falling.   yes
.  With the whole world suffering from water shortages, I
feel that this is a blessed country because, even though the rainy season arrived a little late, it rains when the time comes.  Now,
yesterday in the US market,
semiconductors initially
showed signs of rising quite strongly,
yes.
yes.  It went
up a little.
yes.  I fell a bit in love with Sangbong.
On the other hand, tech stocks also showed some strength, and as
Pro Cheong-min
mentioned earlier, it seemed like
funds were shifting somewhat from the defensive consumer staples sector to the tech and communication sectors more aggressively. The
US market seemed to be moving with a feeling that we could go on the offensive again in July, and
fortunately, the 10-year Treasury yield fell slightly.
yes.
Oil prices are also $68.6.   The
overall market sentiment was not bad,
but the MSCI Emery
and South Korea ETF
rose by 2.2% and 5.94%, respectively.   It
looks like the 3-year performance results are out.   Right
?  yes.   yes
.
Approximately 89 trillion won has come out now,
surpassing the content college entrance exam.   The
concept is about 86 to 88
.  yes.  About 86 trillion.   It
was 86 trillion, but
even so, there was talk in the market that it could go up to 99 trillion
.
yes.  yes.  It came out.  At the very
beginning, Meritz
provided a forecast of about 60 trillion won, which was the
most accurate. Actually,
Meritz talked about 90 trillion won, and
this
reflects everything up to the end of the election, including the labor-management agreement.
yes.  We have reflected approximately 20 trillion won, and we
plan to reflect 10 trillion won each in the third and fourth quarters.
Uh,
20 trillion was reflected, so
why is it decreasing in the 3rd and 4th quarters?  Ah, I
reflected the entire first quarter in the second quarter all at once.
Ah, until the end of the first quarter.   Yeah,
yeah.  Reflect the entire year.   About
40 trillion in total. Yes, that is
correct.
Aside from the results, it turned out quite well.  Right?
yes.  With the actual second-quarter results this year, the
100 trillion won financial strength is now sufficient
.   That's true
.  you're right.  yes.
The results delivered match the stock price rally story that the market had expected
.  Right?   yes
.
Now, regarding the key points to watch in the market,
yes.   Well, this is something
I am currently thinking about, and it is also a
dilemma regarding what kind of portfolio to hold in the second half of the year.
First off, of
course, regarding performance, since interest rates are
currently high,
the key point is whether there are factors that could lower them or if they will continue to remain at a high level. This involves
obvious factors like oil prices, employment, consumption, investment, and inflation, but in any case, I think we
need to examine these areas in more detail
.  Ah,
regarding portfolio strategy, it
seems natural that JP Morgan, Morgan Stanley, and other houses would have different perspectives when it comes to taking a top-down approach.  First of all, JPMorgan
has a preference for semiconductors and hyperscaler AIP stocks in that order, and
regarding semiconductors, they are saying that the recent weakness is a
buying opportunity.   It is being said that while
M7 has a tailwind of earnings and valuation,
derating is expected to continue due to concerns about profitability
.  And regarding
AI-damaged stocks like software recently, it is
said that a technical rebound is possible when they are oversold. Overall, while
there are some differences in preference, it appears that the possibility is being kept open to some extent based on the recent
macroeconomic environment
.   As
interest rate burdens
decrease somewhat, a phase of rotation into the M7 and others is expected to
begin.  I'm
talking about it like this, but the biggest difference between Duus and this
is the semiconductor.  While JPMorgan
currently views the semiconductor weakness as a buying opportunity,
Morgan Stanley sees it as
overheated.  It surged a bit.
And since the positive factors have generally been
reflected, it is being said that the semiconductor sector will take a break, and a
phase of rotation or confirmation into other sectors such as M7 will take place
.  So, the market is
expected to play a tug-of-war in the middle of the curve. Above all, it is best to hold good,
affordable, and suitable stocks with
appropriate weightings. In
any case, for the second half of the second half, it
seems necessary to construct a portfolio while keeping these aspects in mind.  This isn't an easy topic, but in
any case, I
think we need to keep monitoring the macroeconomic environment, and I believe there might
be opportunities in stocks that are slightly undervalued relative to their earnings
.  The June ISM Services PMI was
released and came out at 54.  The consensus was
54, and it dropped by
about 0.5% to 54.5% points, but
employment increased slightly due to the increase in positive items
.  And the storage capacity has also increased a bit
.  Regarding employment,
the factors contributing to the increase have been described, but
not all of them saw an increase; rather, it
appeared selectively. The ISM assesses that it is highly likely that World Cup-related
employment contributed to the rise in the employment index.
In the decline items,
you can see that business activities, new orders, and supplier deliveries decreased slightly. As
for prices, which I have circled,
May
saw a significant drop from 71.3 to 67.7.  So, we previously
looked closely at prices in the manufacturing sector, and at that time, prices
decreased in June compared to May.
Since there was also a decrease in the service sector, we will examine price-
related issues later
.  First off, if
you look at the responses, I
noticed mentions regarding costs, price increases, and bottlenecks.  It is said that suppliers are trying to pass on price increases to consumers due to
rising costs related to accommodation and hourly wage services, while in the agriculture,
forestry, and fisheries
sectors, the financial burden resulting from
increased costs due to the war and losses of feed crops caused by drought is
leading to a reduction in agricultural spending
.  In the construction sector, it appears there is a bit of a bottleneck, as there is an
abundant volume of future project orders,
rising material prices, and longer delivery times for data center
piping components
.   It
was stated that concerns over a memory supply shortage are growing in the financial and insurance sectors, which is affecting product reliability and influencing companies' purchasing decisions.  They are a bit expensive, so I am having
some difficulty deciding to buy them.   I
think it can be understood this way. Regarding the health and
social welfare sectors, it was mentioned that the
possibility of rising costs is being raised due to the ongoing conflict in the Middle East, and while this has
not yet materialized, it remains a matter of concern
.  It was mentioned that demand for infrastructure projects in specialized scientific and
technical services remains
strong.
The comment on the home sales performance was the best; they
commented that despite being the off-season, business performance is very strong, prices are stable, the level of availability is good, and the supply chain is also strong.  It was also mentioned that price volatility is increasing in the power sector
due to delivery delays, supply chain issues, and material
shortages
.  On the Omae side, it is said that
sales are continuously
increasing thanks to price hikes, but generally, issues such as
increased costs, bottlenecks, supply shortages, delivery
delays, and supply chain disruptions are being observed
even in some areas with strong demand. On the
consumption side,
looking at the comments from the retail sector, it is
understood to be quite robust
.
So, regarding the
price index included within the ISM manufacturing index, I mentioned earlier that it
fell in June compared to the May level. Since the
CPI is scheduled to be released next week and
could significantly influence the FMC's decision-making on July 29th,
I am also keeping a close watch on the situation. However, it
appears that signs of a pickout are being observed in manufacturing and service sector prices in April.   If
you look at the monthly ISM price index and the US CPI below, you can see that
as we move into January, February, and March,
prices in the manufacturing and service sectors continue to
rise through April and May due to the impact of the war.   In
my case, the price index hit 84.6 in April,
then dropped to 82.1 in May and 73 in June
.  And in the
case of the service industry, it was 71.3 in May
and 67.7 in June.
So, looking only at the data, it appears that the Jeju industry
picks out in April, while the
service industry
picks out a little later, in May
.  And
[clears throat]
June is showing signs of decline compared to May; it looks like
both the manufacturing and service sectors are
falling.
If you look at the headline and core CPI below, in May, the headline was 2% and the
core was 2.9%. However, for June,
Bloomberg and the Cleveland Institute are
currently estimating the headline CPI at 3.9%, while the
core sector, which is closely related to the service sector, appears to be stuck
at 2.9%, showing
signs of not dropping significantly
.  For now, that is how the market
views it.   Regarding
2022, I
previously
mentioned the slight leading nature of manufacturing and service prices. If you look at the manufacturing prices,
service prices, and CPI below, you can see that
even during the Russian War in 2022,
manufacturing and service prices appeared to
pick out slightly ahead of the CPI
.  After that, it was observed that the CPI lagged
behind by about one or two months before
picking out.   If
you look at this time as well,
manufacturing prices are in blue and
service prices are in red, but
manufacturing already picked out in April 2026, two
months ago.  And regarding
service prices,
according to the announcement this time, it appears that they were picked up in May
.  And
regarding the CPI, it was 4.2% in May,
and the market estimates for this June range from
3.9% to 9%. We
are observing a downward trend with a time lag of one or two months, in the order of manufacturing and service prices, followed by CP. Of course,
since the June figures haven't been released yet, we
cannot make a definitive conclusion immediately, but
looking at past examples and current
conditions, I
think the results will likely be similar to the market consensus. If you look
further down at the CPI contribution by category below, it
shows by color which items contributed significantly to the CPI following the recent U.S.-Japan-South Korea war; green represents
energy.  Energy could
barely shift to CPI even up until March,
but looking at 3, 4, and 5, the
shift rate increases significantly, and the
shift rate is highest in May.  So, roughly
speaking, looking at the bar chart, it is estimated that it contributed about 1 point, or around 45 percent
. Regarding this part, actually, if the
gear ratio itself decreases as oil prices
fall, I
think the overall headline CPI—at least the headline CPI—could decrease.
So, since it is currently around 1.45, 4%,
1.4%, 1.5%, and 5%, I
don't know when this will all drop, but if it does, the
CPI is likely to return to
normal—specifically, around 2 points, or the mid-to-late 2% range, assuming other conditions remain the
same
.
And looking at WTI, which has the greatest influence in the energy sector, I have
illustrated the relationship between the CPI and WTI.  Uh, as the
closest example, in 2022,
when oil prices rose sharply due to war issues, the pick-out points of the CPI and
WTI generally
appeared to be the same.  So, looking at this time,
although oil prices rose as high as $120 during the trading session, the
CPI actually rose sharply in the range where it had been maintained above $100 based on the closing price
.  If we look at it that way, I
have a feeling that WTI or CPI might pick up around roughly the same time as in 2022.
And as if reflecting this in the market,
the estimated probability of the FOMC keeping interest rates unchanged on July 29
was 70.6% on June 26, but
looking at it on July 6, that
probability rose slightly to 74.9%. While we will have to wait and see about the probability of a rate hike
after this, the
probability itself has also
gradually
decreased as seen in September. Since the
other lower-level indicators don't
seem to hold much significance, I looked into it in detail because the
CPI coming out next week seems likely to play a crucial role in determining the market's
color and
direction
.  That's all.   yes
.  thank you
When explaining the market recently, people often ask, "Why isn't the market
surging more decisively?"   yes
.  I would like to explain that interest rates are now holding
tight, and since the
CPI has recently risen from 2.4 to 4.2, that is the
key factor.  However, due to the World Cup, the figures
announced next week for June might be
slightly higher than expected, but
looking at oil prices and the various data you just presented, it is bound to
eventually decline. Therefore, we might
face an adjustment first in July, and as we
move into August and September, the CPI will
definitely drop quite steeply.  Given this
trend, I actually think the August CPI data will be
somewhat meaningful.
Even if it doesn't drop to 3.9% this time, I expect it to be in the
3% range in August
.
yes.  With the market cheering and the
10-year international interest rate falling slightly,
leading to a
rebound, and as the
CPI shows signs of falling further next year, would
n't we see an even stronger rally from the end of this year through the first half of next year?
yes.  I keep mentioning this a
lot. Looking at this
past CPI and the cold weather trends,
today
is a very important part of the data for President Choi.  In the past, whether in the
US or Korean market, and especially in the
US market,
there was always an adjustment when interest rates, linked to inflation, touched a certain critical point. Regarding the
current 4.4%, it is exactly like when I
said that the bathwater temperature is 44 or 45 degrees and it is hot
.   While
there are risks associated with individual stocks and companies, regarding the
overall market
weakness and
interest
rates—as I mentioned—looking through this
CPI data, I am becoming
even more convinced.
The bag must be quite nice.
thank you   yes
.   Now
, let's move on to the domestic market
.
Yes, I will report on yesterday's market.   The
KOSPI closed down 0.46%
.   The
KOSDAQ closed down 2.46%, or 46%
.  It was a
day with very high volatility in the POSPG number.   If you
look at the supply and demand, individual investors
bought about 2.6 trillion won yesterday, while foreign selling is still
continuing.  There was a
sell-off worth around 1.3 trillion won.
Institutions have also been showing selling pressure for about three consecutive trading days, with approximately
1.4 trillion won worth of sell orders
released during yesterday's session.  There was selling of over 1 trillion won in foreign futures
.  If we go
down to the trading trends by investor type below,
foreign investors bought Kia, Daeduck
Electronics, Seoshin Systems, Shinsegae, Hyundai
Rotem, Tess, PSK, Samsung SDI,
etc. yesterday.   On
the other hand, on the selling side,
there was a sell order of 640 billion won for Samsung Electronics, and
in addition, Samsung Electro-Mechanics, SK Square, SK
Hynix, KB Financial Group, Mirae Securities,
etc. were sold.  Institutional buying included
Samsung Electronics (Primary), KB Financial Group, Samsung
Hydrofluoric Acid, Kia, and Hyundai Motor.
In terms of selling, SK Nix, Samsung Electro-Mechanics, SK
Square, SDI, Hyosung Heavy Industries,
Hana Ocean, etc.
There are a total of eight stocks that hit a 52-week high.  The number itself is still a bit small
.  On the KOSPI, Shinhan Financial Group,
KB Infrastructure, Namkwang Towon, and
Hankook Steel reached new highs, while
on the KOSDAQ, YG 1Won, Golfzon
Holdings, and Daewon also made it onto the list of record highs
. Hmm
hmm.  Foreigners in the East, institutions, and electronics
foreigners...
ah, looking below, it seems they
sold Hynex along with electronics.  yes.
Oh, they sold, and
looking at the institutions, they
also went for Hynix. But
why did the stock prices of Hynix and Electronics
diverge so much yesterday?   It
seems that expectations were definitely reflected in the stock price because the earnings announcement was scheduled for today. Also,
looking at the recent decline in stock prices, the electronics division did
n't rise as much and fell more significantly,
so I
think that may have influenced the stock price.
And regarding the talk of the foundry division turning a profit—was that
announced during yesterday's trading session?
Yes.  I think I've seen this.
Uh, regarding the surplus in our hearts, was
n't it said about three or four months ago that we could turn a profit by this third quarter?   yes
.  yes.
Uh, but actually, the turnaround to profitability
won't be reflected in the second quarter results; it could happen
in the third quarter.
I think the third quarter will be a bit higher.
It seems that we have received a large volume of orders from Nanno and have been announced as the top performer in turning a profit.
Oh, really?
습니다.  Okay, first of all,
regarding the reports on the major stocks...
ah, since there is a report on Samsung Electronics by Meritz analyst Kim Sun-woo, whom you mentioned earlier, we will
look at the contents of the report together with today's preliminary earnings announcement.  First, let's
take a look at the major stocks and presidents.   yes
.  Looking at the semiconductor sector first, the
electronics stock price closed yesterday up 2.7%
.
Deathkeynix's stock price closed down about 3%
.  So, in
the end, although we don't look at it in terms of PER yet, we have
reached a situation where the P-valuation is becoming similar to SK Hynix and Electronics again.   The
discrepancy was quite large.  With the
Knicks falling a bit further,
the situation is almost leveling up between the two companies.
Looking at the materials, parts, and equipment sector below, the
trend is not very good.  The recent trend has
n't been good.  Looking at it from the perspective of Once,
almost everything has turned blue.
However, the
US-Korea Peninsula fell 2.6%, and
stocks like Renogui and HPSP
generally closed lower.   The
HPSP is not updating that PR, and it has
dropped to about 20,800
.  So, Reno Industrial, Pa,
Jusung Engineering, Wonik, IPS,
ISC, and Simtek generally showed a decline of over 5%
.  In addition,
Isu Petasis also saw a sharp decline of about 8%
.  Currently, based on women's market data,
valuations have dropped significantly as most sectors are showing a weak trend, falling by as much as 20% to as little as over 10%
.  Well, Reknow has dropped by up to 27 times
.  Well, in the
case of Ioyuk, it went up 40 times and then came back down
to 35 times
.
If we look down at the IT sector, Samsung
Electric fell significantly by about 8%.   There were
n't any particular issues.  I
keep hearing about the situation, but it seems like there has been some stock price correction recently
.  Well, it is still
maintaining a positive trend based on Once.
Below that, it seems there were also some stocks that fell significantly, such as LG Electronics
, LG Notek, LG Display, and Fitech
.
When people said Jensen was coming, companies like LG Electronics and
LG CNS
rose significantly, but that was just a flash in the pan, and a
trend of finding fundamentals has emerged.
In fact, I understand that this was one of the
"sneer-scrutinized" stocks that retail investors bought heavily. As you have
always said,
given the current high-interest rate environment, it
seems this time has also demonstrated that we need to be cautious of stocks that are driven by narrative rather than earnings.
-38.7% 7% In just a month, back
then I heard a lot of talk about things like robots and
collaborating with MB
.  yes.  Well,
since it is currently difficult for such factors to be reflected in earnings, the stock price has already
fallen. As I
mentioned last time regarding LG Innotek, even though the
Plitz BJ business unit accounts for
only 10% of revenue, I
noted that investors had applied a BJ multiple to LG Innotek's overall earnings, which made me think it seemed a bit
expensive. However, the
stock price trend is clearly
showing a different trajectory compared to the previous year.   no see
.  Uh, and the platform sector, with
Naver and Kakao staying about flat,
seemed to perform well compared to the market.  Naver has increased 14-fold again
.  So, the valuation has become quite
favorable.  The Nikkei index
closed at roughly the same level as the previous day, and
well, it seems that the equipment and semiconductor sectors were
generally poor.  Tokyo
Electron, Murata, Hoya,
Ibiden, and others showed a weak trend.
Therefore, Mulata and Ibiden, which can be considered peers of Samsung Electro-Mechanics, also showed
similar stock price trends.
And moving on to the automotive sector, the
automotive sector wasn't bad.
Hyundai Motor rose 2%.  Kia closed up
5.7%, and Mobis also rose 4.2%
.  So, I
don't know what will happen with Hyundai Motor, but generally, the
stock price tends to rebound when it reaches tenfold
.  So I
think we need to look at this part carefully, and the
consumer sector showed an upward trend in household health and cost-effectiveness
.
Cosmecca Korea was also about flat.
Uh, looking at it with a beauty device, my skin was
n't very good yesterday.  Pharma Research fell 8%, and
Classys and Hugel also
showed a weak trend.  Recently, the stock price
had shown a rebound, but it
seems like there was a disappointing trend in the previous session where it gave back some of those gains.   The
food and beverage sector below generally
maintained a sluggish trend, and department store chains
were also sluggish.
If you look at the shipbuilding, steel, and other sectors,
Hyundai Heavy Industries rose 1%, while the morning
closed with gains of 8.6% and 6%.  Uh,
some disappointing news came out last night. It was reported that the
Canadian submarine project has gone
to a German competitor
.  So, Hana Ocean rose quite a bit yesterday due to expectations
.   hmm.  I
think Hana Oseon might have dropped a bit last time as the order went to TKMS in Germany.
I guess we have no choice but to face the stock price.
Since it rose 8% yesterday due to expectations,
well, it would be different if bad news came out
while the valuation was high. However, given that the valuation has
dropped significantly, it might be
difficult to rebound in the short term. Nevertheless, I do
think it would be a bit of a shame for those holding the stock to sell just because the price is falling.  And
looking further down at the defense companies, Hana
Aero was weak.  Rotem
was also weak.  Nex still
closed up about 1.8%.   The
domestic defense industry is currently quite weak compared to global defense companies
.  Uh,
looking at it from a global perspective, it is emerging, so I
think this issue will eventually be resolved.   The
biotech sector generally showed a sluggish trend
.  Uh, Samsung Bio, Episis
Holdings, Celltrion, and KOSDAQ Bio
were generally on a weak trend.
The performance of securities stocks was not bad yesterday.
Korean financial stocks, including Kiwoom Securities and Mirae Securities,
generally showed an upward trend.   I
liked Ento better.  There were no particular issues
.  As HYBE rose to 4.8 GPS
SMYG,
it seems that supply and demand are coming in because this is an industry where valuation merit has definitely increased.   The situation on the
Alliance side has been unfavorable recently
.  Hyundai 1-Rex, Hyosung Heavy Industries, and
LS 1-Rex are all bad.  Hyundai
1RC's
stock price
continues its weak trend despite the disclosure of a 1 trillion won transaction last week.
With forward values, Hyundai and
Hyosung Heavy Industries have dropped significantly to 130x and 30x, respectively
.
[Clears throat]
Alright, [clears throat] we’ve
now gone through the videos of the major stocks.
Uh, after the Samsung Electronics report, and then
uh, since it's another semiconductor report,
uh, since the Samsung Electronics preliminary hearing is out, let's take a look at the
semiconductors today
.  The title of Meritz analyst Kim Sun-woo
's article was that Samsung Electronics' semiconductor business
would reaffirm overwhelming profitability with a pre-provisioning figure of 110 trillion won
.  The content of the report.   yes
.  It was a report that came out yesterday.
Actually, the profit came out to about 88 trillion, and
[snorting] you can
consider it to be about 108 trillion in profit excluding the deposit
.   The
researcher had projected the second quarter estimate at 90 trillion
.  So, the market
consensus had risen to about 86 trillion won,
but it was expected that things would be somewhat damaged
.  Anyway, it seems you got it right, and the fact that
memory prices and shipment volumes are
significantly exceeding the industry average could be the key factor
.  Starting this quarter, DS
special stellar bonuses have begun to be reflected
.  So, we expected the first quarter provision to be
retroactively reflected in this second quarter, and it
seems that has been reflected to some extent this time.  We determined that
actual
earnings are highly likely to significantly differ from market expectations, as the consensus appears to reflect only a portion of the provisions
.   We
had estimated the total operating profit for the DS division to be around 109 trillion won.   It is said that
7 trillion won was reflected for the first quarter retroactive provision of 85.6 trillion won and the second quarter provision of 13.7 trillion won
.  So, the
profit from the memory business was estimated
at 112 trillion won based on operating profit
.  It was predicted that LSI and foundry would
incur an operating loss of about 2 trillion won due to the impact of increased capacity utilization.
SDC's operating profit was projected to be around 580 billion won
.  As for DX,
uh, it looks like DX was cut a bit.
It was projected that MX would turn to a deficit of -1 trillion won and DVD to a deficit of about 150 billion won.  With rising memory prices
increasing the burden of component costs, it is projected that
price hikes and a decrease in sales volume will be inevitable for the set business
.  It was predicted that
memory prices would continue to rise until the end of the year
.  It was expected that record-breaking performance would be achieved every quarter this year
.  The supply shortage due to the lack of cleanroom loans is
still somewhat continuing
.  It was predicted that while the proportion of B2C would decrease,
support for AI memory would expand
.  CSPs were expected to continue
securing memory through strategic cooperation with LTA
.   It was
predicted that memory supply and demand would be even tighter in 2027.  It is reported that the current memory
cycle has not even reached the mid-cycle yet
.  Supply will likely struggle to keep up with the
increase in demand until at least the fourth quarter of 2027
.  Therefore, as the
pace of performance improvement in the electronics sector is expected to be the fastest, we have
announced an aggressive increase in weighting.
The announcement of the casting reduction policy in the fourth quarter is
expected to serve as a catalyst for a revaluation of the stock price.  We assumed the three-year
tonnage to be around 100 trillion won
.  An additional year-end dividend of
around 14,800 won per share
has been proposed, and there is also a possibility of concurrent share buybacks and cancellations
.  The investment press conference
adjusted the usage of the Buy TP to 500,000 won.
So, this time, the supplementary and performance grades
have been reflected.   It seems
like about 9 trillion has been reflected, which is
10.5% of the operating profit in the first quarter.
It's 5%.  It seems that the figures reflected in this profit include 5.6 trillion won from the first quarter and about
13 to 14 trillion won from the second quarter
.  If you look down at the earnings estimates below, the
projected revenue for this year
is 745 trillion won.
And if you look at it based on operating profit, it is on
the right.  Operating profit for this year is
projected to be 388 trillion won
.  Next year's sales are nearly
1,000 trillion.  So, the forecast is 965 trillion won with an
operating profit of 575 trillion won
.  Yesterday,
UBS projected Samsung Electronics' operating profit to be
over 800 trillion won.  Next year's
operating profit.   hmm.
Hynix is
currently estimated to be around 600 trillion won, but since
UBS always makes estimates based on rather bold cases, figures of
that
magnitude are emerging recently
.
And
regarding the LSI and foundry sectors below, it seems that Meritz analyst Kim Sun-woo
still forecasts a deficit for the third quarter of this year
.  It seems that by the fourth quarter, it is expected to reach BP
levels.
Nevertheless, it seems they are still projecting a deficit for next year
.  It appears they are taking a
somewhat conservative approach because no numbers have been recorded yet
.
So, if you look at operating profit on a
quarterly basis, it is
true that the growth rate is declining.  Here on the right, 1Q 2 3
4 is displayed, and the
operating profit was 57 trillion won in the first quarter,
90 trillion won in the second quarter, and 88 trillion won.  It came out.  And
since the third quarter was 112 trillion and the fourth quarter was 128 trillion, if we look at the slope, it can be seen
as entering a downward trend. However, what
we need to
look forward to now is the HBM price
negotiations.  So, looking at recent reports,
there are forecasts that HBM prices will increase by 100% next year.   I
understand that the price negotiations will be finalized in July or August. I am
not 100% sure, but I think a significant increase is
inevitable because
DRAM margins are currently
much higher than H-band margins.   hmm.
Because that actually doesn't make sense,
um.  I think a price increase is inevitable,
so I believe that whether the
downward trend of the slope
reverses next year will likely be determined by HBM prices
.
Now, let's just continue reading Researcher Yoo Young-geun
's discussion on the antibody below as well
.   yes
.  Oh, since it was called the Silk Road that would unfold endlessly, it was
research material on Yu Hyeong-geun instead.   It is
called a memory-centric fortress
wall.  We confirmed an
aggressive buy recommendation for the Korean semiconductor sector
.  Samsung Electronics maintained its target share price at
560,000 won,
while Hynix adjusted its target to 3.9 million won
.
Recently, regarding the trends, the stock prices of Electronics and Nickelodeon had
actually dropped by more than 20% compared to their peak
.
Nevertheless, it seems the target stock price has been raised, and the opinion
itself is becoming somewhat more unfavorable
.  I have listed a few reasons
. There are four.  They say that the first
ripples do not change the big flow
.  It is believed that the sluggish phase of memory semiconductors
remains valid, and
while AI demand continues to expand, production growth is limited, so
the intensity of the supply shortage in 2027 is expected to worsen further compared to 2026
.  It is said that
in the third quarter of the fourth year, when customer demand becomes more rigid, there is a high possibility that a severe
supply-demand gap will be confirmed once again
.  The recent stock price
volatility is assessed to be due to high absolute stock price levels and increased
sensitivity to short-term issues resulting from the concentration of tech stocks
.  Therefore, I
believe that issues raised in the market, such as the sustainability of AI fax, the potential to replace Chinese semiconductors, and concerns about memory price hikes, are highly likely to be resolved over time.  We
view this as merely a temporary tug-of-war occurring during the upcycling process, and we
expect the stock price to eventually continue its upward trend.  Uh, the second is the
expansion of LTA value, and the basic
structure of an LTA is said to be a long-term contract of three years or more
.  It is said that 10 to 30% of the down payment is
paid as a deductible expense
.  It is said that it is highly likely to be configured in the form of price band settings
.   It was
mentioned that the contract extension option is particularly key;
if the structure allows for early extension discussions during the contract period rather than deciding on it immediately before expiration,
suppliers would be able to grasp customers' actual demand much more
accurately
. It was stated that this is expected to
enhance the accuracy of supply operations and mitigate the
high-performance cyclical volatility of the memory business
.  So, I talked
about the price band settings up there.   I
heard recently that there is
no price cap on Hynix.  There is talk that
Micron and Samsung Electronics now have a bit of a price ceiling
.  The third forecast is that the HBM-centered
ASP upward cycle will
resume once again.  We expect the 2027
HBM ASP to rise by more than 100% year-over-year. While the
baseline
scenario is over 100%, let's keep
open the possibility that the increase could be further expanded depending on negotiations.  We even talked about it
.  It is said that they are pushing for price increases by preventing the profitability of general-purpose DRAM from
surpassing that of HBM and by
leveraging the supply shortage environment across all products
.   It is
projected that pricing policies will continue to maximize profitability while maintaining long-term partnerships with clients
.  The fourth point is that
we should look forward to the largest shareholder return in history
.  It is said that the possibility of Samsung Electronics and
SK Nix implementing policies to cast on the largest scale in their history is
increasing
.  The outlook is that the policy direction will become clearer
after the third-quarter earnings announcement, when annual cash flow becomes more concrete
.  It was estimated that both companies possess the financial capacity to provide
shareholder returns worth approximately 100 trillion won
.   If you scroll down to
the table below, you will see the global
memory semiconductor market size and
outlook.  It seems they are looking at
around 1,600 billion dollars by the time it reaches 27 years
.  Looking at the market size
itself and the growth rate, it
seems that 2026 was indeed the peak of the growth rate.  Then, it
seems they estimate that it will continue to decline next year.  On the right is the HBM market
size and outlook.   It is
projected to grow significantly to around 180 billion dollars or 168 billion dollars in 2027.  First of all, the H4 is
scheduled to begin in earnest next year,
and it seems they have
set the price at $168 billion to reflect the price increase
.  It seems like they are
estimating that it will go up by about 100%
.  So,
looking at Y-Y growth, it seems the market size itself is
expected to grow by about 200%
.  [Snoring] On the right are the inventory
orders, revenue, and
outlook for the three DRAM companies.   It
can be seen that the inventory level has dropped far below normal levels;
when the inventory was high, it was almost 25 weeks, but now there are
no weeks left.
We can interpret this as a situation where orders are being processed immediately as soon as they come in, and my inventory is [clearing throat] insufficient
.
Hmm. This is the
first time I've seen an inventory chart viewed from such a long-term perspective.  Uh, if we have Companies A,
B, and C, the memory would be 3 and 4,
right?
Normal restocking takes
about 3 to 8 weeks.
Yes. The
level around this time is considered a normal level of inventory, but there
really were a lot of inventory in 2023. Back then, uh, what was the inventory amount again?
About
50 trillion won.
Looking at this, the
semiconductor cycle has
shown signs of being quite volatile in the past, hasn't it?  Now that the empire is running
low, as mentioned above, I
hope the semiconductor cycle will become a bit more moderate with this LTA.   Right
?
yes.   For both
investors and actual businesses, the
fluctuations were so severe that it was a structure where profits would fluctuate wildly, then
losses would follow.
But looking at it now, there is absolutely no inventory.   It's
just bread.
You're a total punk when it comes to making bread, right?  Since I have to send out all the suitable stocks right now,
looking at the situation, inventory hit rock bottom in Q1 2018 and is slowly creeping back
up.
When should I sell the stocks?
Hey, you don't know where Company A is or anything like that, do you
?   yes
.
First of all, moving into Q1 2019,
inventory had already fully increased, and since
inventory was definitely rising,
earnings shocks began to appear starting from Q1 2019.
However, the
shock actually
started with the preliminary earnings announcements in January 2019, which were released starting from Q4 2018.   Starting
from the front cue.
Looking at it that way, inventory has definitely
hit bottom and is rising.
When inventory trends upward for two consecutive quarters, should I sell the stock
?  Uh, I just
had that thought.   In
'21, '22,
'23... I think it was in
May of '21 that Hynix hit its
peak, so it was
hitting bottom and coming back up.
[Clears throat] Micro, on the other hand, hit a
slight new high in December of '21 and then fell, but this
Company C actually
rose much faster.   At
that time, it
feels a bit like Company C had sufficient inventory. It also
feels a bit like Company C is Samsung Electronics or something.
Anyway,
hey, if we look only at the inventory levels, and just looking at this, if I get the feeling that the stock prices of Memory [clears throat] 3 and 4 haven't reached their peak yet, right? Well, these guys... hmm
.   Right
?  Wait a minute, since this is Q1 2027,
ah, I hear that even the forecasts are fully reflected
. Yes, that is
correct.  About three dotted lines over there seem to be the estimate
.  Since the
earnings announced this time are for the 2nd quarter, that
chart shows that inventory shortage will continue
until next year, 2017 or 2027
.  Ah, that's what was
reflected.   If it goes according to
that picture, then the stock price is
not at its peak.
But how can I keep checking the inventory
?
Improvement is now being mentioned occasionally in the A B reports
.
Otherwise, you can check after the quarterly announcement
.   uh
.  Ah, yes, I will check after the quarterly earnings announcement
.
But recently, looking at Company B here—that
grayish kind of thing—it looks
like the inventory level is rising slightly again
.   yes
.   It
is predicted that it will appear to be rising but then drop sharply again.  Right?  That one.   yes
.
Anyway, looking at it, it seems like I need to keep a close eye on it.
And here, the HBM market size and the
global memory market size are shown,
going back to the past, specifically since 1992.  The data is
yes.  It is an even series.  Regarding the
performance rate and the bar graph representing the
market size, previously, even if you
combined all the memory semiconductors, the scale was actually
less than 200 billion dollars.
So, the memory sector was
200 trillion won and the non-memory sector was about 600 trillion won,
totaling around 800 trillion won. However, with the
recent surge,
it has reached 1,400
dollars, right?  Since the scale has increased, it has become a
2 trillion won market.  The market is
currently at the 2 trillion won level out of a 200 trillion won market,
and among that, HBM
still accounts for about 15%
.   yes
.  If you consider it to be around 15 to 20% right now,
then since HBM is a specialty semiconductor,
among memory types 3 and 4, as Woo-gwa-jeong
mentioned earlier, originally HBM had better margins and was becoming the
standard. However, with the
recent rapid
advancement from DDR4 to DDR5, the
margin for regular VRAM is actually higher than HBM right now
.   yes
.  yes.  Originally, the HBM margin was in the 50%
range.  The margin.  So it
was a very high margin.  We have been
tracking this since the year before last.   yes yes
.
However,
since such a large volume of shipments are going out for servers, including HBM,
legacy RAM is running out of stock.
Even now, margins are still soaring
.
So, the price of HBM can be raised.
[Clears throat]
Yes.
Either raise the price of H, or just
drastically lower the price according to the regulations.
Yes.  It seems like Hm is currently bottoming out and moving towards raising prices
.   I
suppose so.  Since there is no stock right now, it does
n't look like the price will drop significantly, right?   The
warning signs of the city walls are
appearing in the data like this, but wow, if you
just look at this graph of the reassessment estimates, there are
many Silk Roads stretching endlessly, and things are going exactly
as expected.
All right.  And it states that there are expectations for the largest scale ever, and as
shown in Researcher Kim Sun-woo's data above, it
assumed that the three-year shareholder welcome scale is 100 trillion won;
is this 100 trillion won every year?  Or
is it 100 trillion won for all three years combined?   I was saying it was
combined.  It
seems we will have to establish a policy to provide everything again around next year.   is
it so?   We usually
did this every three years, you know.
That is next year.
yes.  I remember it as next year.
And now that I look at it, it says that additional year-end dividends are
possible.
15,000 won.
Now that the stock price has risen significantly,
it would still be good if they paid an additional dividend.   Right
?  It's better than not receiving it.   It's
definitely good.
I would like it done as a special dividend.
And lately,
good news continues to come out of the foundry sector as well.   Right
?   yes
.
This time, Enthrope is going to
entrust the boundary to Samsung, right?
yes.
So, then, what is the current projected stock price for Samsung Electronics
?
-0.6%.  It is expected to fall by about 6%
.
Oh, Hynix is ​​also showing a -3% drop
.   yes
.
So, before reflecting the reserve fund, as indicated in the
title of Researcher Kim Seon-hoon's report, it
came out to nearly 110 trillion.
[Clears throat]
Why is the market's valuation a bit so negative?   It
seems a bit difficult for him to say that it was priced in yesterday, since it went up 3%. As I
mentioned before, I get
the feeling that quite a few people are becoming a bit skeptical
.  I've been feeling a bit out of steam lately
.  After the meta issue, if it used to be like
eight out of ten people
dropping out, it definitely feels like that number is
going down a bit now.
Also, I noticed earlier that so
many people from the opposing group's materials, parts, and equipment departments
dropped out yesterday, too?
Uh, well, there weren't any special issues.  But well,
strictly speaking, the
valuation was a bit too high.
Compared to past cycles.  Of course,
the cycles are different, but with even stocks that haven't posted earnings yet having
risen significantly, I suspect the decline was due to a
lack of supporting supply and demand. I
also wondered if there might be demand from retail investors to sell
Samsung and SK Hynix and
buy Electronics if the materials, parts, and equipment (Sobujang) sector drops, given that everything has already
fallen anyway
.  hmm.
But if we look at the semiconductor inventory cycle and things like that mentioned earlier, they are
currently making a lot of money and
massive investments are being made.
In fact, China's
Changxin Memory and Yangli are also expected to
invest aggressively. Given that, as long as the valuations aren't too high, it
seems like we can just accept the decline in the materials, parts, and equipment sector.  Hey, but earlier you were saying that
volatility in the
semiconductor sector has intensified not only for materials, parts, and equipment stocks but also because of the double leverage on Samsung Electronics and SK Hynix. However, even without double
leverage,
general stocks have all become extremely volatile
.
yes.   I
really need to get
good at surfing.  Right?
What should I do?  Do I just have to be
good at surfing?  Or just
stay still.
I've been doing a lot of thinking lately. Personally,
I view semiconductors as a good investment to hold
or see as a good choice, but
looking at the stock price trends, the market
seems to be saying otherwise. I somewhat agree with that, and I
think that if the market was excessively overheated previously, it needs to come down. In that case, we need to use the money we've lost to buy other investments, right?   hmm.   I am also
a bit concerned about whether buying something else would make a significant difference.
Recently, the market seemed to be doing
well; department stores and
entertainment seemed to be recovering, and while the
shipbuilding industry fell quite a bit today, it had also shown signs of recovery, as had the
defense sector. However, this
trend does
n't seem to be continuing.  Well, I
think that aspect is really difficult when looking at the market these days. Hmm.   Okay
, I understand.   I will look at
how the US market performs tonight, provide a
forecast for the US market, and then wrap up
.
Okay, I predicted yesterday that the entire US market would rise, and it all did
Yes, everything has gone up.  Yes,
right?  hmm.
Today is July 7th.
First off, since it's July 7th, it's the day to grab a 7-won pair and build things up.
[Laughs]
Jang Pro, do you know how to play poker?  Ah,
yes.  I know how to hit.   I'm
not sure if I'm hitting well.  Seven lines.
Uh, if you're not sure if you're playing well, you have to play a round
[laughs], and
if you are playing well, you have to be generous.  That's right.
Uh, I can't hit it.  You shouldn't be able to hit it.
Yes. We
have to play a winning game.
So, what happens?  US
market tonight.
Number rise.
Uh,
expected
rise.  yes.
Expected to rise.
The elder was like, "Should we do the Nasdaq and,
uh, that recommended price
?"
I think I'll get SP 500.  SP
What do you want to do?
So, regarding SP SP, it
seems that the NASDAQ will rise and the SP 500 SMP will take a break.   Take a
short break.  Yes, it's in the negative today.
What do you think will happen to the Nasdaq?
Kim Pro, it looks like the
NASDAQ will take a break too.   I think I'll get some
rest.
Then everyone bet 10,000 won.  [Laughs]
Uh, when you miss each other, just bet 10,000 won each and
go.
So, what happens to Pilban? Hmm
hmm.
[Snoring]
Ah, that's difficult.  hmm.  Well, for now,
after Samsung Electronics' earnings, there needs to be some
momentum-boosting material or something
similar emerge, but I
think a wait-and-see attitude will likely continue next week as we wait for the CPI.  So, I think I will take a
break from Philban as well.
Oh, you're saying Philban is off today?
yes.
So, it is difficult to say that President Choi Bu is
not the type to always unconditionally declare things
.  [Laughs] It's
difficult.
yes.
okay.  There are slight mistakes in the general case as well.   yes
.
Then, how did you start in the domestic market
?
Yes. The
rally hasn't started yet.  yes.   It has been
delivered now, and it started
down to -1.64%, or 64%.  It is still in the
same index range.
Oh, it started at 7,919.   Okay,
next, what about the KOSDAQ? Yes, the
KOSDAQ started down 0.39% and
is currently down 0.45%.   The
KOSDAQ has fallen a lot anyway.
Show me the KOSPI again.  Look at me.   yes
.   It
started at -1.64.
How is Samsung Electronics and SK Hynix doing
?   yes
.  Samsung Electronics is down 2.5%
.  Hynix is ​​down about -0.1%
.   hmm.
Earlier, the expected
stock price was around -2%, but that wasn't the case.   Right
?   yes
.
So, I was wondering if it was really necessary to start at -2%, but
how are foreigners doing right now?
Foreigners are buying 150 billion won.
150 billion?   yes
.
Uh, I'll take
another look in about 5 minutes.   yes yes
.   Okay
, today the KOSDAQ... uh,
yesterday it dropped in a bad way.   Right
?  I felt really bad about it, but
Manager Wang said yesterday that there would be a bearish candle
.
It's a bearish candle again today.   yes
.  you're right.   The
KOSPI was ordinary yesterday.   yes
.
So, what happened yesterday?  I was
hit by a bearish candle yesterday.
Yesterday, the market almost went up to 3% during trading,
and then... yeah, right, it
went down 3%. That's correct.   It
felt like it was just going to end with the provisional law, but
was it around 12 o'clock yesterday?
It's the movement path during the trading session.   It
was very severe.  It suddenly took a turn, and there was some kind of
issue like that during yesterday's trading session
.  Well, there
weren't any bad or good news, but it
seems like volatility is increasing.
Today, the
electronics sector is down 4%, but it looks like it will fall
further to 4%.
And well, since the submarine business has been delayed, the
shipbuilding and defense sectors have
fallen by about 5% or 10%, so I
think we might see a bullish trend today.
Oh, but I'll give way today.
Ah
[laughs]
Actually, there was some pressure on Seong-gu from Muwon.
what?  We need to shout for a long, full candle today
.   As
for the
grass beekeeping you know, we really do have to
expect that all the time, but well, then I will
proceed with my opinion.
Today, a bearish
candle came.  There is a bearish candle today.
Later today, try analyzing the chart with Manager Oh
.
[Clears throat]
But looking at it now, it is at 104, which is
16.4
% from the high. It has dropped another 16% from 9,385.
Looking at it, yesterday I thought it had strongly broken through the 5-month 2-hour moving average, but it pulled
sharply back down, and the closing price
ended without recovering the 5-month 2-hour moving average.  Looking at it,
8,113 was
yesterday on the 5th, ah, the 2-hour moving average,
and today the opening price started below the 5-day 2-hour moving average line again
.   yes
.
The average has pushed down a bit and is
currently down to 7,989, but since the
initial price started lower than that, the
512-pyeong level appears to
still be
acting as a strong, precise line. Looking at the weekly chart, it formed a long lower
wick last week and although it did
recover, it ultimately ended below the 5-week
2-pyeong level of 8,367.
This week as well, 8,304 is the
5-week 2-pyeong level, so it went right up
there, blocked the level, and then fell.  hmm.
Actually, what was very unusual yesterday was that
foreigners [referring to] call options this Thursday,
oh, that's right.
But foreigners [clear their throat]
cover up the call option as a secondary one.
You bought it?   yes
.
Uh,
previously the foreigners' option positions
were set downward, but they
significantly
changed their positions due to volatility, and
200 million yesterday, yesterday afternoon.
Yes.   It
was very unique.   I have
bought a significant amount and turned all my positions around
.
Oh, the position is like that too.
So, this Thursday is the option
expiration date.  Right?   yes
.
Okay, regarding the foreign investor volume... if the stock is selling like that, it
looks like foreign investors hit it.
Foreign investors are selling a small amount.  There are about 15 billion won worth of
sales coming out.  The
overall foreign investor market is currently flat
.  It is almost a protection.
Oh, then who is selling the electronics
?   It's an
institution.
organ.   yes
.  Wouldn't it be an institution or an individual?
Individual investors usually
don't sell at a loss like this.
Looking at foreign investors, they have been
continuously selling Samsung Electronics since June 25th,
but they were doing the same
before that.
So, as of last Friday,
that institution bought Samsung Electronics quite heavily
.  But about 1.4 trillion won worth of
buying orders came in.   yes
.
So, I think the funds probably came in due to expectations for the earnings announcement
yes.  I think that regardless of whether the earnings report turns out well or poorly, there will likely be some
funds flowing out through selling
.   hmm.   There
is still a bit of the actual earnings announcement left, but since there is some
demand to just hit the jackpot right away
.   yes
.   The
KOSDAQ looks like it is turning positive now
.   yes
.   The
biotech sector of the Stock Index is currently showing an upward trend
.   Is the
bio sector strong?   yes
.  The bio sector is strong.  Well,
DND Pharmatech went up about 12% and the
ETF
went up about 3%, so it seems like most
KOSDAQ stocks are going up
.  It seems that as the semiconductor market takes a
breather, those funds are shifting to other
areas for instant buying
.  hmm.
I think I saw in the comments earlier that trading for Hanwha Engine wasn't working in the NXD market. What was the opening price for Hanwha Engine
? Yes,
Hanwha Engine opened at 44,500 won. It
started at -15.88% and has
since climbed straight up to 6%.   yes
.
Uh, shall we
take a look at the chart?
Hana Engine has
fallen nearly 40% from its peak, but it has now
dropped halfway.   Even though it
failed the scoring business today, looking at the morning opening price which was
near the bottom and a bullish candle appearing now, it seems that fundamental
analysts are buying with the feeling that they should have bought at that price level, thinking, "Oh, even though it
failed, the overall performance will
continue to be good
."  That's right.   You'll have to ask
our
match manager about that.
Actually, regarding the engines used in the submarines entering the Hana Ocean, they are
not manufactured by Hana Engine but by STX Engine. This is because they are
high-speed
engines that rotate very quickly, so they have
absolutely
no connection to Hana Engine.   yes
.  So even when Hana Ocean rose, Hana’s
body did
n’t really react much.
But actually, since there is selling pressure on ETFs right now, I
think this is actually a very good opportunity.   uh
.
That valuation is actually about
15 times higher.  And in modern times, there is a
level where recognition is about to break by almost 10 times
.   yes
.  With earnings growth expected to continue until next year
and a surprise expected this quarter as well, but the
stock price falling, it
seems very attractive from a valuation perspective.   hmm.   hmm.   So
, Manager Go is that bearish
candle.
I mean, it's a bearish candle.
No, Dr. Wang, not in a systemic sense,
but just
looking at the fundamentals, should
n't we be buying KOSDAQ now?
Aside from the system, the
semiconductor and stock sectors have all
been foreign language high schools.   It is
becoming a foreign country.   yes
.  Why is it going down?
This isn't just about Jeonse; the
global trend is becoming this way
.
Ah, yes, it is global.  The US is going,
China is going, and blue-
chip stocks are [clearing their throats] all continuously moving down to the next
level.
So, the Chujejo needs to come out, but since
there isn't one, it's really
tricky.   I
think it's really difficult to recommend buying here, even though it's a low price.   It is
difficult to recommend unless it is a purchase recommendation.
Ah, I can recommend buying it.  I
thought it was something like this, but oh well,
personally, that's what I think
.
Personally, though,
because I got burned a lot too.
This is so cheap, and it's
gotten even cheaper.
Well, I
bought it thinking it was 15 to 10 times cheaper, but since it keeps dropping even more, that's
right.  People keep coming forward to do it, and
yes, I
think it is a bit difficult.
Well,
as I mentioned,
that applies to cryptocurrencies as well as gold and silver prices in general, right
now
.  This is seasonality.
Seasonality.  When I divided the US President's
fourth year into
eight parts—the first half and second half of the first year, and the second half of the second—I noticed that in
Korean traditional medicine, the Four Constitutions are
further subdivided to form the Eight Constitutions, and I
think I have heard of that.  yes.
So, by breaking it down into even smaller parts like that, they are
currently treating it all at once. So, if you
divide the fourth year of the US presidency into eight parts, it is [amount].  That's just how 789 789 is
.  So that's why, darn it
?  It is likely to be a market where you feel quite
discouraged, and perhaps even feel a sense of shame for value
investors.
However, if you have confidence in that value, you just need to
hold on during this time.  I
kept mentioning this yesterday, even when I went to Reporter Lee Dae-woo's Wyst, but it is
value.  If you are absolutely certain you bought it at a great price,
please hold out a bit, but personally, at this
price, I feel like I can just average down
.  So, well, that's how I put it
.  However, from the perspective of those of
us managing client funds, we
cannot fill our portfolios with stocks that are being lost so easily. Therefore, we must initially
fill at least 70% of our portfolio with stocks that have strong immediate earnings momentum,
and the same applies to other institutions
.  I am doing that, and as a result, this
depleted stock is becoming more
depleted, and there is a seasonal capacity
.  Those Hatch Fund guys will be back
again by the end of October this year
.  yes.  Since it's July now,
about 7, 8, 9, or 10 months.
So, for those of you feeling empty inside, I mentioned yesterday on
Warmsinbak that
my mother's art exhibition started yesterday, so since I
have a slave named [Name], I would like to
tell you to go take a look at the exhibition, go on a vacation during the hot summer, and rather than getting stressed while staring at your account, it would be better to take a break and a sabbatical year—yes, you can even do some restful stock investing.   Please let me
know where Terranno is so I can go.
Terranno DB Financial Center.
Ah, it is DB Chapter 27.
Ah yes, I understand.   There was
no entry.  [Laughs] 27
My mother will be there.
[Clears throat]
What kind of person is Park Jeong-ho's mother?
[Laughs] If you do that, I'll go and say
yes.
I think it would be fine if you met your mother as well.  Yes, that concludes
today's Chesley Morning Briefing for July 7th
.  We hope you have a
wise and happy investment experience with us in this volatile market
.  Thank you.
thank you
[Clears throat]